[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell kind of movie did you put
on the schedule Chris I'm holding it
responsible if I have a terrible time or
if I have too good a time also movie
opens with the rules of a male strip
club for no other reason that I can
think of other than we really need to
issue a warning to the people who
accidentally walked into this auditorium
after buying tickets to Ted or madea's
witness protection last one lady I don't
think these ladies are paying attention
I know that or they're not taking this
quiz seriously well this is what you
came to see you write trainings tatum's
take a good look because you ain't
seeing anything else from him except
another brief but shot way later in the
movie and it barely registers half a job
scene does not contain what happened
last night you saw these things Thanks
exposition girl forty seconds of just
driving one Pepsi a day read the core
boss has a one Pepsi a day rule when the
rule should be zero Pepsi Zaid a sudden
car trouble out of nowhere allows these
two to become stripper bros so nine
minutes in don't you feel like it just
got tricked into watching an art film
about construction workers or an origin
story about the Village People hey no
what I said was she not drinking this
beer the whole time did you not see her
order it and drink most of it already
this guy is not only addicted
girlfriends he's addictive being
observant I can't drive tonight I've
been driving all weekend of it I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm actively rooting for all
three of these fuckers to fail it
whatever how big is this city that it
has a thriving nightclub and strip club
scene but it's also small enough for
these two fuckers to run into each other
twice on the same day as afraid
don't worry man you're gonna read your
cute guy you should be suspicious of
this remark it's not remotely suspicious
if this remark please okay first
sinister the ultra hot girls at the club
talking like this second sin is for the
guys sliding in with the me please bull
and the thirds Ennis from that bull
working Jesus this movie is so bereft of
male stripping my sympathetic lady boner
is already shriveled up won't you come
down and see the show
this is the male version of the hot
girls who come up to talk to you and you
realize all they want to do was hand out
Jack Daniels t-shirts oh you're gonna
worry about the Waffle House to begin
with and why you're going after it when
you could be masturbating penis pumping
I don't know it's just G it's it's
basically like getting drunk without all
the calories you mispronounced raped
almost 20 years after Dazed and Confused
directors are still indulging Matthew
McConaughey's alright alright alright it
takes 21 minutes for Mike to be magic
so from step up to this movie a what
percentage of Channing Tatum's film
career is owed at least in part to his
ability to dance sexy dance moves It's
Raining Men cliche oh sure I do this at
a Denny's and get the cops called on me
training Tatum does it at a sleazy male
strip club which is an employee and it's
all okay
Channing Tatum can get away with
anything Adam gets infected with Nomi
Malone disease his dude from CSI Miami I
guess I should call this cock scene
investigation Tampa before they move to
Miami and call it CSI Miami again women
are probably feeling all empowered by
this male stripper movie making so much
Bank at the box office and they probably
should be but I'd like to point out at
the 24 minute mark all the major
characters we've met thus far are men
his stripper routine mirrors his day job
now that's stripper synergy or stripper
gee but in a public simulated blowjob
absolutely no one wins so this is what
these ladies came to see the immaculate
chests of the dancers because I haven't
seen one of these guys go full monty yet
and that's a rip-off for a $15.00
advance ticket shadow penis of hugeness
almost 15 years after his arrest for
doing this directors are still indulging
Matthew McConaughey is playing bongos
for the neighbors thing none of the
dancers can even fake a routine to make
up for the guy who can't do it
forgetting that they're at a strip club
where all the ladies want to see is some
male chest and maybe a bolt or two and
they're happy but honestly it's just
some bullshit to get him up on stage you
all need it Mike decides to force Adam
to go on stage something that Dallas
allows for some reason despite not even
wanting him to work here tonight because
he's under 21 any
whole could have done something like
this and it would have been okay but
character development as stripper is
character development there's danger she
pulled a knife on that kid out on the
plank like that good work Bo Dallas you
act like you're not the owner of this
place Mike
you act like none of the other strippers
could have gone out there and did
anything and gotten the exact same
reception cameraman fails at his job
Louie cheats when it tries to copy the
spider-man kiss Dear John stop jumping
into the water to impress girls signed
your ex-wife from Dear John I manage a
few businesses okay cool well the
original cut of this film had the
narrator popping in here to say these
two are totally going to bone you are
the man on the stage thousands of women
um that clump we saw holds at most one
to two hundred women I'm concentratin
movie that is trying its damnedest to
make me uncomfortable has succeeded
Mandy shopping you got a lot of work to
do don't quit your day job just yet
you mean that day job as a roofer and we
haven't seen either of you go back to
since the scripting started in this
movie that day job I guess people are
this stupid so it's not the movies fault
but damn accidentally leaving your
stripper clothes out so your sister can
see them it's definitely a sin I mean
just put those anywhere asshole I'll be
out in a minute please
once that apparently the discovery of
stripper clothes means you can't wait
until someone's out of the bathroom to
talk to them about it it's for wormed
okay three minutes for work how could it
possibly be for work and that's
apparently where the argument ended and
nothing else was ever set okay so either
he told the sister where he worked and
she still came and yet she's still
disgusted or she somehow followed him or
tracked him to his work place because
she was so worried about the leg shaving
incident either way sin you better take
care of him you don't even know this
dude why would you a think you can trust
him with this task or B think he'd be
trustworthy with any task oh hey you
work here at the police I disapprove of
with my brother and I met you one time
I'm putting it all on you Kurt
these ladies look genuinely delighted to
be thrown sweaty pants mr. magic Mike
roll credits also doesn't this feel like
an 80s movie somehow squeezed into
modern cinema it's that cocktail
rags-to-riches entertainer thing that
showgirls was trying to parody right I'm
guessing Tom Cruise is one of those
dancers Val Kilmer or Anthony Michael
Hall as the other think about it Patrick
Swayze would have been killed in the
role of Dallas and the soundtrack how
glorious with that thing a bit I just
want to hear the words come out of
Steven Soderbergh's mouth that he simply
wanted to make another step up movie
just with dogs you know for the art
character throw something random on top
of something
inside a suitcase that is key to the
next scene but blocks your view if you
weren't ready for it cliche that's a
beautiful necklace element oh it's
marine so vintage or not she definitely
shoplifted that thing
brought the funds from my down payment
sorry if these stacks of money smell
like sweaty ball sack I'm asking for is
it could deal if Ricky dude made 230
dollars in one night of dancing and
you're the star he probably made over
$500 last night which means you're
pulling 2,500 a week at least that's
eight thousand a month or salary
annually of ninety two thousand why do
you meet alone I hate fun Jesus Christ
you better have some epic plans if
you're gonna turn your back on a sambar
party somehow uptight and humorless
person is coaxed into getting on a boat
early in the morning just because she
shamed into it I see this is the section
of the movie Zach Braff directed I hope
I get to meet your kid someday she's
really standoffish like I think the
after sweat further with it than the
script called for why would anybody like
her here's the Deline fourth celebration
at a male strip club I see everyone's in
their fatigues but that seems like more
of a Memorial Day or Veterans Day
celebration where are the Redcoats
Where's George Washington oh so you
don't think George Washington is sexy
that's unpatriotic man
this guy gives zero shits about this
routine yeah sure that straightens the
dollars out but doesn't really drain all
the man grease you know with all the
various different numbers I've seen
these strippers do since Adam first came
here I really do wonder why they
couldn't have just done one of those
instead of putting Adam on stage Oh
another stripping montage yay
also male stripping what do we think of
it so far oh I think we have enough time
to discuss it during this montage I'm
really actually surprised how little
nudity there is at these things it's
definitely an r-rated strip club but
it's not rated for strong language in
some suggestive material more than
anything sex related Jesus did she sign
an insurance waiver I don't think she
did this is stupid dangerous let me get
this straight this dude was in here with
this hot blonde chick and they were
fling to the hurricane news on TV that's
some stuff right there man you know for
kind of what month it is oh thanks what
do you want some credit are we fighting
these to have as much chemistry is a
couple of trees also after the initial
roofing scene we've not seen him spend
one day on any of his businesses except
the failed loan application no he's at
sandbar parties and house parties and
fun parks buying beers at noon I think I
know now why he needs the loan actually
got a sorority tonight I'm like a half
hour
half hour you live in Tampa and none of
you were showered or dressed or even
sober so you're gonna be late ma'am
sorry 500 bones that's your freakin
sister man
so yeah why we're dudes invited to this
party if male strippers were hired to
come crash it also but why are these
guys pissed
think about it fellas these two men are
strippers they're not going to sleep
with any of these girls what they are
going to do however is get them all
worked up and horny and then leave them
alone here with all you studs so turn
those frowns upside down okay I realize
you don't have much on but that is still
a terrible hiding spot for the tiny bag
of drugs and now the bags back in his
fucking hand again and when he puts it
on the bill that's hanging out on
purpose
why the wasn't even trying to hide it at
first don't understand it has my Felson
why is it that in every one of these
types of movies the downfall is usually
drugs I mean can't the reason ever beat
dignity in a new movie central conflict
is happening right now but decides it's
time to interrupt that for Adam telling
Tobias about losing the pills and while
I agree that's important shouldn't we
keep a little focus here you want a
bigger piece come up with some fresh
shit man you're not getting any younger
and that's all they had to say about
that Mike told Dallas that this was some
pressure but it pretty much looks like
the same old I guess with all the dollar
bills flying onstage we're supposed to
think that this does indeed constitute
pressures they're going to get so fucked
up it can only be filmed in black and
white I can't do this anymore
what finding him od'd and passed out and
driving him home naked cuz this is the
first time that's happened you hear me
well maybe the moment he wakes up from
his overdose coma isn't exactly the best
time for lectures I'm just saying if you
want it heard and remembered the speech
is completely empty of the people who
made this movie ever been to Tampa in
the summer empty beaches my ass broad
henchmen dudes don't blow away Mike when
he unthinkingly rushes them in the
middle of their ransack job luckily or
unluckily Mike just happens to have that
amount lying around at the house so he
can cover Adams debt I don't know I can
maybe sign over the band until he can
figure out something out I think you
helped something out this is really how
we're gonna end this are you serious
who is this movie about I thought it was
the young kid but every now and then it
becomes about these two who'd never felt
like a decent couple for me to root for
anyway perhaps because of all the
runtime devoted to stripping montages
but I digress yeah I said everything in
unison
got a lot to say yesterday yesterday
didn't all this happen just this morning
even if a day is passed I am confused I
promised you that I would take care of
him and I didn't you didn't just not
take care of him though man you straight
up lit that horse right to the ecstasy
well am i Magic Mike right now talking
to you yes I mean oh we've seen you do
is drink do drugs everything you see and
party constantly just because you have a
furniture design dream doesn't mean
you're not still a partying man-whore
job that's not who it's not what I
that's the case you were wondering
whether this movie even had a script
Channing Tatum's improv skills saved the
worst for last to give you that definite
no you need for closure on the matter
look there on watch three months ago I
ran or not it mean rewinding back
through all the stripping montages and
terrible romantic chemistry also three
months finally those unnecessary month
based title cards pay off right Dallas
is dancing here in the final night in
Tampa but the entire movie hinges on him
saying I can't go out there the first
night when the dude went down injured
and they had to turn up the kid and I've
been wandering the rest of the movie if
Dallas has some injury or something
since he clearly seemed to be a former
stripper and now here he is just fine
and I guess that first night he refused
to dance to save his own show because
he'd read the script who he decides to
make us believe that Dallas show is so
amazing women are throwing not only
dollars but themselves on the stage okay
so with Dallas backstage and all the
other strippers back here what's going
on outside are women just cheering for
an empty stage right now and now that
was really a lot of money and you do not
have to do it I wouldn't do it for him
what that sounds amazingly honest but
it's doable do you get some food and
talk about well I guess like a date
character throws earlier words of
another character back in their face in
the end cliche can't say anything
anymore
who broke up with him well isn't that
convenient seriously I think Soderbergh
set out to make the most terrible 80s
movie set in modern day possible and see
if anyone noticed well I noticed mister
Soderbergh I've noticed that's like
seven hours and no mm-hmm what could we
do with seven hours I mean right nice
and neat happy ending here complete with
suggested marathon sex and as we all
know it works out for the best because
Kody Hornet slated to be in Magic Mike
XXL oh she isn't well you've lied to me
movie you lied right to my face also she
went from I hate you for nearly killing
my brother and I'm not into your
lifestyle and I have a boyfriend too
whatever I want to fuck you now in like
a day
coming soon Magic Mike too even though
he's not a stripper anymore is this
equal going to be about his furniture
business Steven Soderbergh directed this
this is like getting Peyton Manning to
play for your pop wonder team the cock
rocky Dean's
[Applause]
[Music]
can you touch it touch this okay touch
this
[Music]
[Applause]
once you get said word equity Li VI in
[Music]
they're bigger faster stronger more
experienced and on paper they're just
better and they know it too
I don't to tell you something that they
don't know they don't know your heart
you can bet your ass if they'll be
gritting their teeth with every snap of
that football
[Music]
this Bank is not in business it's in the
works or not okay I'm not I'm not a
pornographer though I'm an actor now
this this is a new business for me all
right it's a real thing that I want to
do it's a real thing that I can do
please